it's time took care of it time to check
in with the caravan Greg what do you got
caravan you know no matter what stays in
the news and I think you'll be familiar
Anthony this week that a group of
migrants approached the border they
closed it down the u.s. customs
officials actually use tear gas on it
it's been on them it's been a huge story
children were there the president
denying that they used the tear gas on
children even though there's there's
video of it and you know the migrants on
the Mexican side of the border continue
to try to get across listen first of all
let me go right off the bat I think it's
insane to use tear gas on children it's
so easy to get them to cry
normally that you don't need to waste
the gas to gases for adults for kids you
could just like throw shampoo in their
eyes
Jimmy as long as it's not Johnson
Johnson you're gonna you're gonna get
some tears there secondly I've crossed
the border at Tijuana I've gone to
Tijuana for the night and come across
well you've gotten to get to you know
you were not with me this was just me
and Paul McGoldrick one night where you
went home we were in San Diego drinking
that today I have to Tijuana I did well
and if you go across the board even as
an American citizen even as the probably
greatest American citizen of all time I
got two guests it's just what happened
the Tijuana border
I just let's go back to how this will
affect them in the coming weeks you know
as a team athletically because they
showed me a lot hmm you know if you can
pick up your kids one under each arm and
run that fast from a cloud of teargas
then that shows me something that shows
me that you belong maybe you're maybe
not a starter but you're gonna be good
in the locker room you're saying that
this like the caravan the the struggles
that they're having at the border almost
serve as kind of like a caravan combine
it's good to Widow out for the the
talent evaluators who can who can do it
who can it's a little bit of it's a
little bit of a combines a little to see
who really stood out in those pictures
and you know there was certainly like a
mother who was seemed like seemed like
she could play center for the Niners and
I mean as a compliment like she was
really carrying those kids away from the
cloud of yeah yeah where she's running
away from the full thing you don't see
that you don't
some cornerback from Ohio State running
the 40 with kids in his arms and also
the caravans had it too good for so long
they need to take an L on this one as a
character-building thing it's like if
you're undefeated going into the
playoffs you almost want a loss right
before the end and I think the caravan
having to backtrack a little bit you
know I think that's a character-building
thing you know I mean that next time
when they get across the border once
once our military runs out of tear gas
to use against them and they're able to
enter the country seeking asylum that I
think it's just gonna help them win win
some more games so you're saying the
migrants in this case are almost like
the 2007 Patriots like they've been
winning by too much it's been too easy
no for them during the season they're
they're undefeated and that this this
obstacle this struggle could could help
them listen let me make this clear Greg
let me make this clear let me speak this
online in a language you can understand
No okay the caravan is the 2016-2017
vegas golden knights no one expected
anything from them mmm they didn't have
a fan base to start but now they are all
anyone's talking about people are buying
the gear you know if you go to Las Vegas
you'll see a lot of people wearing
migrant Caravan shirts it's I think
they're the they're the vegas cold
nights
I think the caravan I think the caravan
is all of us our next story is from the
NFL involving Baker Mayfield you may
have seen Anthony he was noticed it got
attention last week for at the end of
their win over the Bengals in which Hugh
Jackson the former Browns coach was just
fired by them was on the sidelines came
over to kind of give him a hug after the
game Baker Mayfield didn't want to give
him the hug just kind of like shook his
hand had some things to say about him
after the game that essentially he
didn't appreciate you know Hugh Jackson
now working for the enemy and the way
that he left Cleveland and what do you
think about that do you I've seen people
be like oh that was bad Hugh Jackson did
that I think I think that if someone
fires you you can go do whatever you
want you know it they fired him he's got
to get a job yeah but I don't mind Baker
Mayfield being real and
not having to pretend like he likes this
guy which he clearly doesn't like the
more telling thing to me was he was
responding on social media to some some
guy was criticizing him that's who
really annoys me or the people that I've
been criticizing Baker Mayfield I don't
have a huge problem with you Jackson but
the people that are criticizing Baker
Mayfield for just kind of sticking up
for himself and saying what he wants I
think it's a bad look for Baker I think
it's like criticizing an ex he's not
wrong but it's a bad look I mean you
don't have to hug him and this is like
for all our child listeners out there
all the small kids this is like a
learning thing if an adult man wants to
hug you you don't have to let him you
could do a Baker Mayfield did but you do
have to do a Baker Mayfield did and let
him rest his hand on the back of your
head you have to let him touch the back
of your head and hold it there for at
least 1 seconds and then let it go I'm
against Baker Mayfield I think it's I
think he looks classless he keeps he
keeps on going back to this know his
coach cup he doesn't he doesn't like the
coach that's fine but the cool thing was
when the the Browns guy intercepted the
ball to so stepped out of bounds just so
he could hand it to Hugh Jackson that
was a baller move Hugh even handled a
cool game a little slap on how much just
dropped the ball at his feet which is
the coolest thing he could have done
I'm on Team Hugh Jackson I hope he
coaches the Bengals next year and I hope
he and Baker Mayfield make love after
the next time you're playing yeah you
gotta keep your hug circle tight again
don't have to let someone hug you but
you do have to let them hold their hand
on the back of your head that's a good
touch Greg what's the next headline make
it a good one make it something make it
something serious something like think
about sports for once it's a great one
it's it's Cordero Patterson the New
England Patriot wide receiver and
running back added to his versatility
this this week when he showed that that
he can he can squish he can grab some
dick and balls when like if that's what
you're looking for and you're running
back slash wide receiver like he can do
that Henry Anderson one of the defensive
tackle the Jets whereas just kind of
standing above him and lingering there a
little too long like shoving his crotch
kind of in Patterson's face and
Patterson gained some notice basically
by just kind of kind of grabbing it and
in pushing up I see when I survive it
when I heard about this play I thought
was like a stiff arm situation you know
I mean like he's running down the
sideline somebody's trying to tackle him
he squished some dick and balls and
you're like okay but then you see the
play it's well after the whistle I got a
say after watching it and let's play the
clip I mean he clearly really grabs
there and and really gives a good
squeeze yeah it sounds it sounds painful
let's play just show it one more time I
just want to see yeah see that's a long
time right there you can see it he
doesn't lead with the helmet and I think
if you're gonna grab if they're gonna
grab a dick and balls are we gonna
protect quarterbacks and defensive and
offensive coordinators more than other
players yes but if you don't lead with
the helmet mmm go ahead and squish to
compose back in the day when the NFL was
a man's League that was that was every
single play you got they threw a flag if
you didn't do that it was fine Dick
Butkus forget about it yeah that's why
he can barely walk today
because of all the dick and balls
squeezes they got in between plays but
yeah I was it was a penalize able play
they didn't always throw a flag if you
didn't do it but it was you know one of
the tenants behind the game it's one of
those things that it is tough with kids
like you think about how am I gonna
explain this to them like what the NFL
really we used to be and what it is now
cuz as far as I saw like there should
have been no flag on this he's outside
the pocket he's outside the pocket
totally it's totally illegal so illegal
if you're not allowed to grab your dick
and balls after the play put a dress on
him and call it something else cuz it's
not football
[Music]
you